all right here we go
okay
before we go we don't just go hang on
pause here we go we don't just go we
don't just just go because when are we
just sorry here we go when the podcast
starts well so we thought we'd try
wait are we starting did we start
i don't want to waste your breath thank
you
we thought we'd try watching one back
and talking about it as we watch it yeah
just something different is that going
to work this is well we're about to find
out together yep
guys it's great to see you it's great to
see you um it's always great to get
together and see you guys for the
podcast yeah we are in our new studio
once again
and we're gonna watch this next now
this next episode isn't necessarily a
special one that deserves this but we
just got in fact i have very little
memory of this episode at all yeah i
think we just got a little you know we
get bored and we like trying different
things we never just do the same thing
based on the title
frank said sweet dmphy i remember him
throwing
a match down the well and lighting her
on fire i remember us doing the camera
the the news you want to know where do
you want to be surprised as you go well
you know maybe i'll be surprised i i i
this one because it's a big blanket
watched it already oh you did because i
thought we were that's what we were
doing but
okay this instead okay great so you're
seeing it for the second time in two
days we're seeing it for the first time
in 10 years
i know cause i did a i did a whole
re-watch like uh maybe a year ago oh
okay like before we did the podcast so
you're you guys are a narcissist no
sorry
no
no no i didn't i did what i thought we
were going to do is watch it ahead of
time i didn't know we
[Laughter]
you just have to individually text me
because i cannot stand a group text oh
wow yeah
i'm good for like
three you don't like group texts no
no
do you like five people talking at you
at once
but it's not that it's it's it's one
person talking at once yeah
i turned the ringer off because i can't
stand bling bling bling bling that's why
i'd like to get rid of my phone i'd
actually like to not have a phone
anymore i kind of want to get off social
media yeah and not have a phone but i
don't think i can get away with that
it's
that's that you know because i do like
being able to
look something up protect the weather
yeah
yeah that's right or music i like music
options yeah no i like all of it that's
the problem that's why i want to like
the upsides you don't like the downs
yeah that's right i'm gonna go back to
defending myself of why i did a re-watch
oh because it's all about you sorry go
ahead you you
well it one you know it's mo it's mostly
about me um no i did a re-watch in
anticipation of writing season 15 of the
show i took two years off the writer's
room well i see that's professional
right and as a professional i was like
you know what i want to make sure that
we're not doing more of the things where
we you know accidentally write something
in that's not consistent with the uh
the lore of the show and then and then
we ended up doing the skating episode
anyway
all right um
i'm with you um all right let's try this
[ __ ] rewatch idea
[Music]
already it says tvma language and
violence
violence
and violence just just play stuff and
people want to watch the budget you're
just paddling around with the guys
how's anybody going to get hurt classic
all right
okay so
we just watched the cold open
uh
and let's talk about it yeah
okay i want to talk more about how
charlie hates this he just hates it i
don't hate it because we don't know
what's going to happen we have like
hundreds and hundreds of these of these
podcast episodes but we just we're just
trying [ __ ] he just doesn't trust that
it's going to work i'm not convinced
that it's going to work but i don't know
this is the worst case scenario
uh that's good that's a good question um
worst case scenario is that it's kind of
boring
and we have to redo it no no because
we're going to talk about the episode
anyway and we can jump ahead
this cooled open
yeah oh it's a funny [ __ ] in there
a lot of us justifying what we're about
to do and why we're about to do it yeah
a little heavier hand than we would
maybe use now but that it's it plays the
news thing is funny like just a little
clip
new soccer yeah i like that i like it
with something that i feel like i used
to i used to feel about like the actual
news and reading the news but don't and
haven't for a long time but like this
whole idea of like
yeah like okay so they're smuggling like
[ __ ] [ __ ] into plutonium into syria
like
great
the [ __ ] does that have to do with me
you know what i mean like that just the
complete like
lack of uh understanding of the uh you
know how the world works and how
everything is simple butterfly effect
a nation such as syria having access to
nuclear yes right there's a lot of
people who probably watch that clip and
are like [ __ ] yeah i'm with you like i
don't what do i totally what do i care
when something happens outside of
you know
where i live and then there are the
people who like
maybe get satire more of that which is
like well this [ __ ] that happens outside
of where you live can still affect where
you live but right
that's the show uh but those are the
same people that want to know what paris
hilton wore last night you know i mean
i'm going by the way i mean back in 2007
not now yeah i don't think anybody cares
what she's wearing now or maybe they do
this this episode is very dated in that
regard because there are paris hilton
references and there is uh
basic cable references which is like uh
no not local local access local news
local no there's public access public
access public access yeah that's what it
is yeah which is that's not still a
thing is it public access sure
how do you get it how would you get it
now oh cable you're on cable yeah all
right all right well should we keep
going
on something what happened here he's on
coffee was it it was the coffee right is
it is it agitation i've been i've been
on different time zones
um yeah you've been on some different
times
i was in the texas time zone and now i'm
in the uh
california two hours two hours yeah
that's enough yeah threw me a little bit
um
i've watched this episode already and i
don't want to have to watch it again
yeah that's part of it i think yeah yeah
um see that what else
what else is this coffee there's some
coffee coffee
have you eaten today
i haven't i didn't have a proper meal
i've kind of picked up some things
that's part of it
and and then it's my spidey sense of
like that this isn't the best way to do
one of these episodes
um
you know very creatively passionate has
your spidey sense ever been wrong
no never
no
i mean occasionally i let you guys
think that
yeah yeah i think think that you were on
the other side otherwise i'd be
unbearable but uh no i'm usually [ __ ]
right um let's continue with this
oh we're going to watch the whole should
we talk about it
okay
here we are we're going through uh
philly you guys ever heard this one
[Music]
there we go executive producer listen
there we go i like our title sequence
it's a train station and it's a dairy
queen and uh created by rob there you go
i do enjoy that it's called it's always
sunny in philadelphia and the entire
title sequence is shot at night
yeah that's good nobody watches that
[ __ ] there's all sorts of great stuff on
public access oh is there well let's see
what kind of thing was this dancing guy
so to hire this guy we just like uh we
just
well we just like
picked an extra and we said show us your
dance moves no i think we had people
audition we might have had we had a guy
we had a guy in mind there was a guy on
venice beach i still think he's there oh
oh oh dances he had the little silver
ball yeah
and kind of like a bodybuilder yeah yeah
yeah i totally no he was totally yeah
and he and
and we brought him in i remember wendy
was like uh our casting director was
like no no you can't it's not gonna work
yeah he's not going to be he's not he's
unwell he's unwell yeah i remember that
either that as well you always wonder
about the guys like that though you're
like is he unwell or are we unwell
because look think about that guy's life
he's unwell he [ __ ] um think about
his life he works
out about his leg
he's [ __ ] dancing in his underwear
with a silver ball for a [ __ ] loose
change in the streets
[Laughter]
you don't think he is he wasn't asking
for money no he may have been
independently wealthy we don't know he
he he he was never going to be dead
wrong this is a [ __ ] great idea and i
told you as much
this the
no he he he he always looked happy as
[ __ ]
he always had headphones on he was
always [ __ ] jamming and music and
listen and like dancing and playing with
the silver balls and the [ __ ] hanging
out beach all day you got you gotta look
happier they don't tip man you gotta
look happy i don't think he ever i don't
i don't ever remember there being a hat
or never he was i think he was just
experiencing life that's what i'm saying
i i think he was happy as hell yeah just
one of those people just floating on a
cloud all day [ __ ] long great good
for you
anyway we had to hire
he was great but you know then i think
that guy i remember that guy came in
right and he saw his tape and there was
something upsetting about it we were
like oh this is kind of
dark there's a darkness
whereas this guy it was very like uh
there's a darkness too but
it's an enjoyable darkness now i love
this time i do enjoy the fact that he's
wearing he's got underwear and cowboy
he's got a serious farmer's tan as well
and we gave him little to no direction
you know no this is who's where these
were his moves he came in with them yep
he came in
get a couple up skirts a couple nip
slips boom you'd be famous like that
well yeah i think i'd like to avoid the
nip slips and upskirts but i think i see
where you're going with this i'll tuck
you into it at some point and i could be
famous just by being frozen absolutely
great good luck with that this was
before
the kardashian thing really caught on so
this was back when kim kardashian was
just friend one of paris hilton's
friends yeah are they friends was that
where they were
i don't know
she was a spin-off of paris hilton yeah
but
i mean it's all phenomenal i mean think
about
like it
it used to be sort of like you could
make the joke like oh this person's
famous for doing nothing but then like
you know
jokes on you man because they that's
right
taking that to the stratosphere they
sure have
yeah anyway
that's like it's like the progression of
them but they don't they're they're
but they are industrialists are they not
big time yeah yeah no they're they're
they they've created an entire business
out of it but uh i still find it
disgusting
oh wow
why sure
i don't like it there is something
annoying about being famous without
having a thing like don't think man like
uh you know what they don't but now
something they are doing somebody
figured out that
what they do first is they become famous
and then they do the thing yeah right
they become famous for it's like it's
interesting it's like a total inversion
right some people do the thing and they
become famous for doing whatever the
thing is and then these guys were just
like well why don't i just be famous
first and then when i do the thing it'll
be way more successful because i'm
already famous yeah actually by the way
you got to give them credits like we'll
just film ourselves being us which
basically is what that's what we're
doing right now and uh it worked they
they became you know all we talked about
or cared about yeah to be clear i i
don't i don't have a problem with the
the whole idea of becoming famous in
order to create a product that then is
successful because you're using your
fame to do the thing
but like
what i found disgusting initially when
when the whole like uh inf
i guess it was before even that term
existed probably an influencer right
like the whole paris hilton thing of
just like being famous for literally
doing nothing just just
showing up places and being a socialite
being a social life you know like i just
i just personally i
but you know what that's also
that's also i think you know that's just
a personal thing i just i just i don't
like that i just don't like it
i think it turns out it feels
i don't think you're alone in that i
think i think it was
you know i think
we got we got forced into it in a way
like we broke us down we eventually just
became a part of our yeah
society or dominated our conversations
well we're used to we're much more used
to it now but i mean back then that
whole thing was just completely bizarre
you know yeah you know don't just
do a booty don't just have to be here
don't just be a butt just be a butt yeah
here you go three two one look at that
good afternoon philadelphia this is matt
coming to you live from the malvern
retirement home cool face hold it hello
miss what's your name
irvine simon is there anything you want
to tell the world
my grandson's birthday on friday no no
is there anything about this place that
you don't like
the blacks
okay all right all right we got it
that's a good scene that actor is
amazing she's amazing amazing singing
like we still make that joke yes we
would right definitely
yeah she's an old racist ladies and
gentlemen racist lady that exists homes
are full of them yes absolutely shockful
and elder abuse is something that is
still happening and going on and maybe
we wouldn't use the term ass rape
maybe we would i don't know i think we
would i think because what the joke is
that danny is just saying that loudly in
the room yes
and we're like what shut up what are you
doing you know i love that we just walk
up to someone and start filming them too
which is pretty great
um
okay all right this works again this
works the scene was very this works this
way you think i added the cool faces
hold it hold it and that was impossible
i think that was in post i do remember
that was impossible because because you
probably weren't you were probably
behind the monitors at this point you're
not whole actually holding the camera
yeah i think someone else is playing i
think you're right yeah
yeah and i think i think we were
watching it and we just we saw some
little beats yeah needed a little need a
little
yeah cool face hold it cool face hold it
[Laughter]
all right
here we go we figure let's get out of
the sleepy nursing homes let's go to a
place where
we could run into something cool yeah
and chinatown we think has lots of
mysteries so let's go check it out is
what's coming up fish being traded for
fish okay yeah i'm excited about it
what the hell are these guys doing
they're just training fish for other
fish is what it looks like
this isn't gonna lead to karate oh i
think what we gotta do is find one sick
guy and do a story about a new pandemic
[Applause]
we oh pandemics we predicted pandemics
wow
a wet market we just predicted is that
what they call them wet
yeah yeah a wet market we're in a wet
market where we predicted that there was
going to be another pandemic and you
guys were going to report on it before
it
yeah we called it do you think we
manifested it somehow we took a long
time to manifest yeah well viruses
usually move a little bit faster than
that okay all right let's just keep it
going yeah
okay wait that i remember distinctly why
why what they passed the same fish back
yeah yeah that was not in the script
you know they were given very minimal
direction yeah these were all guys that
lived on the street yeah they lived in
on this street in that street we just
grabbed them we're like hey you guys
mind passing fish backwards yeah we
didn't do it but somebody did on our
behalf and paid them 50 bucks a pocket
and we were just in private because we
noticed they were just passing the same
fish back that we thought it would be
funny to comment on yes yes here in
chinatown where a large crowd has
gathered for what can only be a martial
arts showdown you look scared i'm i'm
sorry i'm not just sweating it's very
very hot marshall okay martial arts expo
just just go in go away so we're hoping
for some we're hoping for some martial
arts because we're racist and uh what
they're doing is they're playing because
they're playing weebly
we also predicted people watching other
people play video games sure so uh you
heard it here guys we've predicted
almost every major event the last 15
years that's right and then this is what
happens
oh god
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and he had a good he spit the [ __ ]
thing out like spit the hell out there's
a good trajectory on that thing a weird
choice to point at someone's face and
say yeah i saved your life [ __ ] yes and
i would like to get back to that guy
like because that's funny to me yeah
calling people [ __ ] is funny yeah
okay yeah we can work on that yeah
something that we i don't know why we
decided to do this but
we always kind of stuck with our our
characters being a little bit behind on
technology yeah so like a better the old
tv better cameras existed yeah no one
was using vhs at this time but but our
characters were still using their old
yeah we had the old tv we had the old
vhs
there's an old flashlight on top of it
yeah an old flashlight yeah it's funnier
[Music]
hey you guys remember last week when
athletic greens decided to pay us a
bunch of money to promote their green
powder absolutely green for green well i
got some great news guys athletic greens
has agreed to uh
advertise with us again they've come
back they've come back
and i'm here to tell you right now that
we are endorsed by athletic greens it's
a great it's a great drink rob you're
having some right now well i have been i
i was a little bit wary at first i'll be
honest with you because i've seen you
drinking this in the past yes and i was
like ugh if glenn drinks it you don't
trust me exactly if glenn turns out it's
actually good i don't trust it and it is
actually good
you know
it's good you get the fast recovery you
get the mental clarity and the alertness
you know i could use that yeah totally
and it's like the best kind of
multivitamin that you can get and with
this you're choosing ingredients that
your body can actually absorb you got to
be able to absorb it
for your body to use it plus i gotta say
it doesn't hurt that it's endorsed by
tim ferriss and michael gervais who's an
athlete now the scientist in me likes
that they're constantly adjusting the
recipe based on science you know you got
to try this stuff out for yourself we
can't you can't just take our workflow
no yeah and to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a free
one-year supply of immune supporting
vitamin d and
five free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
sunny well tell them where they gotta go
well where they have to go is
athleticgreens.com
sunny to take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
here take this what is this
you'll see
[Music]
this is good glow stick dancing yeah
now what was that song like we just won
in our library it sounds like go go for
it but it's not but it's in the same
i-s-c-o it's
yeah some cheap song that we're able for
like because they'd never be playing
this music no no no no this is what we
could afford it would be playing
something that some people think sounds
better but doesn't
no i don't recall where this location
was where this club was oh god um
somewhere near i think our stages maybe
i think he was actually in west west
hollywood west hall i think it was in i
think it was a west hollywood location i
i'm not totally sure
i've
never left a club with the sun up oh
i don't think i ever have
i have many times i i i
i hated clubs
well i worked in one
so you so i would leave you work for the
club yeah upper west side
venue
it was what it was called and i would
leave you you'd leave at 5 00 5 30 in
the morning ugh that's the worst thanks
god what were you bartender barbara
barback
yeah
yeah i needed a couple of times just
wipe down the loads
[Laughter]
where i was one of the customers at some
club in new york and we and i was there
until five six in the morning and that
is the that is the worst feeling in the
world walking on us yeah
i could not
stand
uh clubs and hadn't
you know back in the day when
people around me and fr my friends were
like wanting to go to clubs and stuff i
haven't quite figured out yet that like
oh
the reason people are enjoying this is
because they're on drugs
right yeah
so i would go and i would drink and i
would try to talk to people
but you can't talk in a club no yeah and
i didn't want to dance because i hated
dancing in clubs so then i'd just be
standing around [ __ ] just being like
what do i do i don't know what to do in
this place i can't have a conversation
with anybody i can't i'm not on drugs
like
the point of it was to take the drugs go
dance and then find a partner to leave
with see i know that now but i i you
know i don't know i wasn't hanging
around with enough people that were
people that were i wasn't i wasn't as
successful as i would have liked to have
been yeah yeah so i stopped
yeah stop doing that i
i don't even think that that exists
anymore the kids do something else molly
i've never done molly because that's my
time has passed it's basically the same
thing i mean it's it's just it's like
pure mdma as opposed to ecstasy which is
a mix of mdma and other [ __ ]
countries now there's fentanyl and
everything so yeah let's not let's let's
stay away from that kids that's not a
good kids and adults let's take let's go
ahead and say real problems
it's not it's not that simple though
some people are getting like dosed they
think they're getting something else and
they're getting dosed with fentanyl it's
really it's no good it's really yeah
awful and that's what i'm saying like
let's just stay away from all of it
don't do drugs kids
drugs don't do drugs why don't you take
my picture now
it's gonna work okay you're not famous
yet you're just some stupid drunk chick
you slept in her own puke
oh come back tonight let's go come on
rise leave
[Music]
now this was
this was not too long after she had hurt
her
foot broke her foot or something right
this season she broke i think she had
just come out of the booth back she
broke her back in season three yeah this
is season three yep yep yep so that was
gonna break her foot she also brought
her broke her foot in season three yeah
she broke both her yeah so as i recall
uh she was able to slip out of the boot
just long enough to shoot these scenes
but like you notice she barely walks
in this season oh
so we've got her standing in the line
and then we've got her just lying down
and then we have her getting up but we
don't ever see her into that trash
though
that's because she's a
pro maniac and then she comes out of a
building on fire so well uh
i i'm noticing that something that i
feel like we haven't been doing is we're
sticking with characters for a couple
beats
instead of just popping
back and forth from one to the other one
to the other like
we were in our storyline for a couple
more beats and i feel like we would have
been and now we were in theirs for
multiple i don't know sometimes we do it
passing thing yeah too you know what i
mean i don't know
i don't know yet all right
hey kirby sexy news guy
it's mac yes it's mac and he's on the
channel whatever we make it on news
i'm gonna make it on the tv all right
here it is
did you make that song yeah you made
that oh for sure down the spot right you
made that up that was like one of those
yeah sometimes we start doing a scene
and we're like yeah it needs something
else and we just for sure i feel like
you can see rob laughing but like trying
to make it look like he's wincing from
the massage yeah
that's
accurate cannot believe you guys i could
have been killed well somebody had to
save those kittens see yeah they were
trapped inside a burning building
deandra you set me on fire we set the
building on fire you just happened to
catch on fire barely yeah we put you out
this is one of the first times we did
something a little special effects
happening yeah yeah right like i don't
know that we'd ever done anything quite
that special effects heavy before
because obviously she was not on fire
how did we just cgi
yeah that was fine because we were so
far away yeah from the character yeah it
worked hey what if we set up like a
conveyor belt situation right put the
cats on that and at the end of it a
chopping mechanism
[Music]
[Laughter]
because that was not scripted no no no
let's drop count can we watch that can
you just skip back 15 seconds and let's
just re-watch that jump cats laugh at
the
and we kept it in
yeah because
it's okay for your character to laugh at
me a chopping mechanism
[Music]
let's chop cats no we don't actually
chop the cats the things that aren't
working for me just like are like a
couple logic things like well why
wouldn't dennis want to be the famous
one right and like her being
maybe just like i think i'm gonna be
famous just by being in a club like just
a couple
like a lot is working but there's like
some logic things that i feel like
i don't know just aren't as good as or
as thought out as they could be i do
like the episode there's lots of big
laughs in it so i'm not [ __ ] on the
episode i'm just saying that that's
where i don't know well not our best
yeah versus the episode
before the gang sells out i felt like
everything was maybe a more believable
motivation for characters yeah that's it
that's all that's the only difference um
what are your outfits of these episodes
what your outfits in these episodes yeah
it's crazy i think that was like like
that was like the look that was like
at the time because this was like
affliction
melrose ed hardy yeah just anything on
melrose avenue yeah
oh cool
uh the bottle thing
it
makes me genuinely uncomfortable end of
episode
pedro lopez also be like the subject
matter too is like
not like yucky in a way i don't know
like
diaper time and [ __ ] do you guys
remember that cable
show in new york new york one like
where it was like news during the day
yeah and at night it was robin bird
robin we talked about this cinema on the
podcast i don't think so i don't think
we talked about robin bird um so it was
like soft core porn yeah yeah like well
it was
yeah i it was like kind of like naked
she would have like stroke
men yeah it was it was both women and
men and they would be well there was men
for men it was meant for men and then
women from for government and then they
would come and they would basically be
all for men it was all for men it was
men for men and women
for men and women
and they would do like stripteases
yeah there would there wouldn't be any
like fornication no but they would
destroy but they would strip naked and
then they then they would plug what
strip club they were working at in the
city oh really yeah that's what that's
wow
yeah oh okay yeah i wonder is robin bird
still around uh is she still with us
she was uh she was already falling apart
she was something else she was something
else she had like a dominatrix outfit on
and she was she had to be in her
seventies yeah for those of you out
there
yeah
just just you know just do a quick
glitch
search look at some robberies
[ __ ] it was the was it the world was the
diaper
she might have just let a rough life man
like at 45 you know not everybody she
was doing
porn on
public access in new york and 20 years
ago the robin bird show in 1977 that's
when it started
seven seven seven episode features bird
in her trademark black crochet bikini
and white fingernail polish on an all
red set with a large heart-shaped neon
sign that bears the name of her show 77
so
uh when i
so i didn't have a tv a lot of the time
that i lived in new york um and then it
was like a couple of maybe the last two
or three years that i was there in the
early 2000s where where i caught where i
was living in an apartment that had a tv
and and uh and i remember i actually
have a very sp this is
i know i've told you guys this story so
i acknowledge that but like uh
the craziest [ __ ] thing i ever saw on
new york public access tv was and it was
i was
i remember was watching this my my
roommate at the time
one of my roommates guy named darren
petty
and uh darren and i were somehow like
flipping through the channels we came
across
pub public access and it was just a
close-up
of a guy's butt just a close-up of a
butt not moving just still
and a hand just a hand coming into the
frame every so often
to dry shave the butt
and uh and it was just it was literally
that that was the show right it was just
a guy's work
what public access was no sure yeah but
yeah basically um now the the part that
got interesting though because darren
and i were like what the [ __ ] is this
you know
but of course just like almost anything
public access you're like well don't
change it like let's see what happens
you know what i mean i want to watch
this guys let's see where this is headed
oh yeah it's weirdly compelling because
you're like what is this what is this so
the guy's butt's getting shaved and
darren and i start noticing it's getting
closer and closer to the butt crack and
we're like
so now at this point we're invested
we're like
how far is he going to go is the story
going hey so yeah where's the story
going how far is he gonna get in there
right
so
then the guy
opens his butt
with his hands and the guy keeps going
and
and the best part is like again the butt
is like totally still and as he gets
closer to the [ __ ]
wait you were seeing the butthole on
public access
or was this i don't remember dvd you
stumbled upon no no this is public
i don't think we saw the butthole but as
the but you know you could see that that
was where the razor was headed and the
guy was kind of pulling his ass cheeks
apart but i don't think you could
actually see the butthole
but you saw the hand get closer and
closer to what you know because you know
where the butthole is
so you know where it is
uh but the best part is as it keeps
getting closer and dary by this point
darren and i are like riveted
you know what i mean is sitting forward
in our seat like it's a [ __ ] action
movie we're like we're like
oh my god he's like really he's getting
really close to this guy's butthole
and and then you just you just see at
certain point you just see the butt
as it gets really close to the butthole
you see the razor
and the and all of a sudden you hear you
just hear a guy go ah
and the butt just moves a little bit so
he got
there like oh he nicked his butthole he
nicked his butthole with the thing
i don't remember past that point i think
darren and i turned it off at that point
we're like i've seen enough
yeah there was a lot moving weird song
on the robin bird show too it was like
right uh baby let me bang your box
baby let
is no but well but the but she was
singing it she was singing she was about
well she was singing it about herself
and saying that she's been banging since
she's a little girl since she was a
little kid see that kind of that's
upsetting there was a dark but there was
a lot of darkness okay wait let me play
that oh let me play devil's advocate for
a second okay let's say this it says
joyful as the bald guy in venezuela i
think
he's probably on that show i think it
was super like sex positive i think it
was a it was a strange time in new york
obviously in the 70s and 80s where
there's a lot of sexual repression going
on right and like in the gay community
especially in the gay community and like
so you have now you have this show
that you can tune into
and watch something that you that you're
attracted to that makes it feel a little
bit less yeah weird i don't know yeah
you're into some kinky [ __ ] you're
you're you're just i don't think anybody
was like into it like very few people
were like
do you remember the scene in the movie
basketball diaries yeah where
he tries to cheer up his buddy michael
and perry michael imperioli is the actor
who's got cancer he's like dying right
so he takes him to the peep show and the
thing slides up and the woman's dancing
and then she's like disturbed that he
looks sick and he's not enjoying it and
the whole thing is it's a really dark
yeah scene
that that's what it felt like that's
like what that feels like to me where
it's like
no it was definitely no one's enjoying
it people feel like it's like yeah
there's a
there's a
it's not evil
i'm trying to think about it
i think you nailed it i think that's
right it felt seedy yeah yeah so it felt
seedy
that's the right it felt lonely
yeah i think
that's right it was they felt joyless
i don't ever remember watching it and
thinking well this is hot
no no it was more like this is fast this
is fascinating yes it was fascinating
bang your box
the catchphrase was i mean the song was
i mean i remember the song so i watched
enough of it it was sex positive as you
said guys i got to pee
okay go pee
or maybe what he's going to do
is
so she came out as bisexual later
yes
oh really thank you robin
so yeah mary she was banging boxes oh
yeah she used to oh that was yeah she
she would the women would dance and she
would like lick them
or pretend to like lick them
did you guys ever do any public access
were you ever on public access and or
the news when you were before you were
on tv not that i know of
i don't think so
i used to host a public access show in
uh in kalamazoo really like yeah i mean
my friends and i in high school as like
part it was like we got credit for it at
school for like a communications class
or something hosting a call-in show
um in kalamazoo michigan on public
access and it was just people calling
and it was all live like broadcast live
and it was just people calling in and
every third person would just yell [ __ ]
and then like that was it that was the
show what was your theme song
i don't think i don't even know if we
had a theme song it was like so low rent
um
but i hope that footage doesn't exist
anywhere which is why they did it
yeah do you feel as though this was a
successful format i don't know i think i
i think it'd be interesting to see how
it how it would cut together well you
know what we should think about
let's let's have people comment on it
and and see if they bit they like it
yeah do you want to see more of these
like this where we watched where you
watch us watch the show and or you watch
the show with us
you know do you want to see that do you
like that you into it yeah no more
that's that your weird thing yeah that
kind of creep for your creep are you
yeah what did you were you sex positive
in that bathroom
i i'm not sure i know what that means we
were wondering if you uh were so aroused
by the butthole story that you just
needed a minute yeah give me a second
here
i remember a time where i was more
aroused than i've ever been
[Applause]
well
i'm out of juice i don't know about you
guys no we got we got more in us right
what's how much how much time have we
wasted
well we watched the thing which took up
some time but
yeah just about done it let's see if i
have an e
let's let's let's dig deep let's find
something because usually the last
minute thing
ends up being kind of the best thing
okay let's see if we can dig deep and
find something
okay
i mean
deeper than your butt shaving story
that's pretty good i think that's gonna
i don't know sometimes i feel like i
tell stories and you guys don't enjoy it
as much as i expect you to i enjoyed it
i enjoyed it
i enjoyed it very much
[Laughter]
i love that story i have just a general
question about the show for you guys and
meaning to ask
how do you guys feel about the fact that
the show is like spawned so many memes
like in the last episode we were talking
about the jobs firing off the job cannon
and everything there are so many memes
from the show that it's like almost his
own internet language yes i do okay so
so i've seen a lot of it's always sunny
memes out there um but i didn't know if
that was because people were sending
them to me because i'm on the show or
if that was because they're really as
ubiquitous as as
ubiquitous it doesn't matter
anything to me oh nice
there you go nice right
how about that
see how i use the word meme
yeah it's meaningless
god [ __ ] off
um i don't know i'm i don't know i mean
i i'm always interested to see what uh
what catches on and what doesn't so if i
see a meme from something
it kind of extends into the episodes too
where we make something and we go oh
people are really going to enjoy this
one we think that we think that the
audience our audience understands this
or will love it and maybe it's like a
shrug and then we'll make something and
think
i don't know that one was fine yeah the
biggest example that's coming up where
we where we put the night we thought
that we completely screwed up that um
not the nightman cometh musical but the
first time we sang the nightman song
and we cut that episode together we
hated it so much yeah yeah yeah we just
stuck it at the very end we're like
no but the main thing i mean it's um
i mean
it's it's cool i like it i mean i i find
it very uh i don't know i'm pleased that
uh we've made an impact i see that one
of uh i'm playing both sides so i always
come out on top people post that like
all the time when there's like a news
story or something like a
pastor who preaches against
homosexuality having like a gay lover
yeah yeah i don't know what our impact
is it's very hard to feel from the
inside right like
sometimes you feel like the show is
giant and has reached everyone and then
sometimes you feel like now we're we
have our sort of niche audience and we
sort of exist outside
the
zeitgeist or
culture in general like and it's it's
it's both frustrating and also
i like so it's frustrating at times to
to feel like you're not getting sort of
wide recognition but at the same time
like when i think about most most of the
artists
you know actors bands musicians that
i've liked the most have occupied this
same space
you know a space where it's like they
make they make a very specific kind of
thing
for a certain type of uh listener or
viewer
and
it's it's almost like because
authenticity is so important to me in in
artistry that like
um
it's a sign of authenticity to me you
know and so it it makes me feel like
when something's too popular i i i worry
that it's that they're pandering
you know and it turns me off
um you know but there are plenty of
examples of like huge bands that are
some of my favorites of all time like
pink floyd and radiohead i mean those
bands are huge but i wouldn't say that
they've ever those guys ever pandered
so i'm going against what i said but i
think the the fear for playing both
sides so that you can so that i always
come out on top um
yeah i don't know but memes uh
it's like i don't like
i don't think about it at all do you
think about it i don't think about it
i like to see a good me i don't know
i like it i said it makes me laugh
i'm interested i'm interested in your
posture
i'm tired yeah yeah are you talking
about no did you get on steam
you know it's like i got sleep like
midnight and then the [ __ ]
i mean we wrote this into the show but
like the there's always something
beeping and one of the fire alarms at my
house started just beeping that the
battery was low
at like five in the morning or whatever
what else has been beeping in your house
the [ __ ] smoke detector so i gotta go
around rip the goddamn smoke detector
out of the wall then i got the wrong one
and then the ladder's missing
you know
big house problems
big house problems
um i don't know
what else i don't know i listen i tried
i tried to pull something out of you
guys
god bless
oh yeah we got home
place out charlie play this out buddy um
what do we want to
let's uh let's write a quick musical
about shaving buttholes yeah
uh what do you think
see if you can figure out baby let me
bang your box
oh
no i can't remember baby
no i don't remember it babe uh
[Music]
[Music]
you know that's how she sounds now
sure
right
yeah
know i don't know that that's how she
sounds but she had a tv show in 1970
something but she's only 40 years old
what was it you [ __ ] think you could
just steal my theme song and get away
with it i wasn't gonna come after you
well now she will your ass is bye
this is new york city this is new york
city we don't take that [ __ ] well
actually it's uh
it's hoboken it's a basement in hoboken
baby let me bang your box
i got this
they shaved my butthole
they got too close
they nicked it a little bit
you say it's gross
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's great all right bye everybody